Where you want to be
that's the question didn't it
you sure don't seem too freaked out about
all this kid what you doing out there all
by yourself anyway exploring the world
sounds fun but why stop at one world
when we can show you all of them we have
you out there a ravager never flies solo
i said never flies solo ah is
that some kind of catchphrase
you had me wear it for a second
journey to face the unknown
and ponder the question
What if give me the tour
Welcome back everyone this is my marvel what if
episode 2 trailer video what if black panther
became star lord so we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of easter eggs it's probably
going to be one of the best episodes of the
season if you didn't think episode 1 was crazy
enough like that has felt pretty similar to the
plot of the first captain america movie it's what
if make it as crazy and bonkers as possible i
think that episode 2 will deliver on that in a
much better way much more to what you're expecting
from a series like what if just based on the pitch
if you've ever read the comics it gets really
really crazy if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes there's 9 total during
season one there'll be nine total during season
two as well careful for spoilers from what if
episode one if you haven't seen it either because
connecting this to the loki series and the way
they explain the marvel multiverse what happens in
future episodes sort of builds on the craziness of
the nexus event that started in what if episode
one even though they're kind of treating a lot
of these early episodes as if they're happening
in different universes think about the way the
watcher was explaining it during the previous
trailers and during episode 1 so captain carter
becomes the first avenger history goes down very
differently in that universe and then that one
nexus event in turn creates this whole different
giant branch of the multiverse this giant branch
of the timeline that has many other branches that
then split off in the future so during episode 2
as you can see from the trailer footage they're
doing a combination of the guardians of the galaxy
1 and guardians of the galaxy 2 movies with black
panther's origin story in the marvel movies so
even though we've moved into a different universe
than the universe we saw during episode one it
flows from peggy carter's nexus event in episode
one i'm sure i'll probably have to explain this
a little bit more when i post my full episode two
video just like how does the multiverse work where
is this branch of the timeline where are all these
different branch universes coming from but in this
universe where t'challa star lord comes from you
have ego the living planet still going around
trying to create his hybrid children on planets
all over the universe in order to find one that's
compatible with his cosmic power so that he can
terraform the entire universe to become part of
his body thereby giving him total control of the
entire universe but the whole idea is that instead
of picking up peter quill during 1988 yondu and
the ravagers have a huge derp and accidentally
go to wakanda to pick up a young t'challa who's
about the same age as peter quill pretty close
to his age thinking that he's the one they were
sent to earth to pick up and you have a version
of young t'challa who just dreams of the stars
looking up at the sky wanting to explore what
lies beyond the border of wakanda he decides to
go with them they're playing in a more hopeful way
even though yondu probably could have stolen him
probably could have kidnapped him if he wanted to
i've seen a couple of you asking those questions
in the comments how did the ravagers break into
wakanda if it's supposed to be the most defensible
place on the planet you have to remember when this
scene is happening when they show up with
young t'challa here this is during the late
80s so their level of technology isn't quite as
advanced as it is in present day when we get to
the events of avengers infinity war and avengers
end game there were many different technologies
and ways that they hid wakanda from the world as
technology evolved even though at various points
in history the technology of wakanda is always way
more advanced than everywhere else in the world
it was still a little more primitive during the
late 80s but the whole idea here is that young
t'challa is just looking for adventure like all
right sign me up he gets all the backstory that
peter quill got being raised by yondu yondu is
also the person who names him star lord becomes
his surrogate father but yondu mistakenly thinks
that he's ego the living planet's son when he's
not the version of peter quill from this planet
is still ego the living planet's son on the dl but
the whole context behind the name star lord still
makes sense when you're talking about t'challa's
star lord because he's a prince of wakanda he's
heir to the throne so his nickname star lord is
still very apropos in the mcu the whole idea is
that peter quills have celestial like little g
god as ego said during guardians 2 so he's
sort of like a prince of the universe in a
cosmic sense just given the rank the celestials
hold in the cosmic hierarchy they're going to
have a little bit of fun with that when we get
to thor love and thunder i'm sure just because
gore the godbutcher is going around killing all
the gods in the marvel universe and peter quill
would probably boast that he is kind of like a god
because he's half celestial but in this universe
because you have t'challa star lord growing up
with yondu being a ravager it dramatically alters
the course of history in the universe way more
than you'd expect so when i say this episode does
a much better job of delivering on the premise or
the promise of the what if series like show me a
timeline where things are way crazier like show
me the alligator loki version of a black panther
and guardians of the galaxy story they have a
lot of fun with this twist so even though a lot
of these scenes from the episode in the trailer
you see are all scenes from that first and second
guardians of the galaxy movie with black panther
star lord stealing the power stone from morag
korath trying to hijack him with his soldiers if
it wasn't clear though the idea in this and the
original guardians of the galaxy movie is
that peter quill and now black panther are
stealing the power stone because the ravagers had
a contract with the collector during the original
movie even though they played it like the broker
didn't want to reveal his client's secret identity
who originally took the contract out for the
power stone it was the collector the whole time
thanos and ronan who was still working for him
at that point were also looking for the stone but
they weren't the ones who had the contract with
the broker in thereby with peter quill and the
ravagers as you can see from the footage t'challa
has a version of the milano just like peter quill
they still go to nowhere taking the power stone to
the collector to earn their money who apparently
in the what if universe is super ripped james
gunn said in the live-action marvel movies he
and benicio del toro designed that character to
feel kind of like space liberace just super fancy
and super weird but weirdly powerful in a way
they never really get into they kind of hint at
it during the guardians of the galaxy movies he's
one of the elders of the universe but they've kind
of been playing it fast and loose with that in the
mcu so far so he's supposed to be super powerful
but they kind of brushed over that and then he was
summarily killed off screen by thanos when he came
to steal the reality stone which the warriors 3
had given to him during the thor of the dark world
post credit scene so i think the what if tv series
wanted to redeem the character just a little bit
and give him some genuine fight scenes like he's
way more badass than you thought that he was
which is where you see t'challa star lord and
yondu trying to tag team him in that fight
also reminding you of the guardians of the
galaxy movies these are also where we get
all the howard the duck scenes for those of you
wanting more howard the duck in the mcu this is
canon to the mcu it's just this is happening in
an alternate universe we should be calling it the
marvel cinematic multiverse now seth green also
claimed that he came back to do the voice there
was a question about that earlier this year
because there are a couple marvel actors that
didn't come back but for the most part it's all
the marvel movie actors playing their characters
i think the idea is that it's just way easier
to do howard the duck because it's animation
so they just had a little bit of fun with that
like okay just give us way more howard the duck
some of you also might remember that there was a
short-lived howard the duck tv series kevin smith
was working on for marvel that would have been on
hulu but they wound up cancelling that a couple
years ago when kevin feige took over all of marvel
television shows but the howard the duck show that
he was working on would not have been the same
howard the duck from the guardians of the galaxy
movies it would have been like a totally different
comic book version of howard the dug the whole
idea with kevin feige taking over all marvel
television shows is that all their television
shows that they're producing now with a marvel
studios banner or canon to the mcu which is why
there shouldn't have been a question if what if
was going to be canon because it's being produced
by marvel studios all the stuff that they produce
themselves is canon to the mcu so just general
rule of thumb whenever they announce future tv
shows on disney plus if it says marvel studios
if they use the marvel studios intro it means it's
canon to the mcu regardless of what the show is or
what they're covering or whether it's animated or
live action but the other big stuff that's going
on in this alternate universe guardians of the
galaxy black panther plot is thanos gamora and
nebula because they were all huge characters
in that original guardians movie and because
the whole idea here is that t'challa becoming star
lord radically alters the history of the universe
the idea is that these alternate versions of
thanos gamora nebula are all very different as
well although their backstory up to the late 80s
and mid 90s is mostly the same it's really not to
the early and mid 90s when t'challa becomes very
active as star lord that history really starts to
diverge in this alternate universe and remember
the whole idea of the what if series is kind of
using a version of final boss form ultron is the
main big villain for their version of avengers
infinity war meaning thanos isn't going around
forming the infinity gauntlet during that period
and it's because they're doing a version of what
if thanos became good and did not snap half of all
life in the universe this is where we get back to
that whole peggy carter nexus event peggy carter
becoming a super soldier alters history on her
world radically in turn leading to more and more
branch timelines alternate realities being created
in the future in the domino effect you see more
dominoes start getting toppled over more and more
branch timelines more alternate realities down the
line as you get to the events of the guardians of
the galaxy movies t'challa has become star lord
in another universe and also because of that and
other changes in that timeline thanos decides to
stop his quest to balance the universe and becomes
a ravager instead the whole vibe of t'challa's
ravagers are also way more altruistic rogues than
peter quill's ravagers too slightly less dirt bags
in this universe they're more like a group of
cosmic robin hoods stealing from the rich and
giving to the poor in for example the collector
is super super rich as evidenced by his massive
collection inside nowhere the alternate version
of gamora is still thanos's daughter but now you
can see why she's wearing his armor from avengers
infinity war and wielding his giant double-bladed
sword and all the trailer footage because her
version of thanos isn't using it anymore he's
turned good so he's not going around waging
wars on every single planet in the universe
the producers revealed that chadwick boseman did
a total of four episodes so there will be a lot of
him during season one but the whole idea is that
episode three will be the first big avengers based
episode with a huge twist on the marvel phase 1
storyline episode 4 is supposed to be the doctor
strange episode with the alternate version of his
origin story that leads to him becoming dark dr
strange the goth version of doctor strange but
if there's any other big questions that you have
about the episodes or the logic or the way they're
explaining the multiverse during all the different
episodes just leave them in the comments below and
i'll make sure to include that in my future bonus
videos my full what if episode 2 video will post
next wednesday just like normal there'll probably
be a couple other bonus videos that i'll post
during the week like i said that episode should
wind up being a banger everyone click here for
my full marvel what if episode 1 video in easter
eggs and click here to learn what's going on with
the avatar the last airbender netflix tv series
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!